So congratulations--you've now built a search engine.
You've got all of the components that you need for a search engine.
You've got a way to collect a corpus,
using a Web crawler that you built in the first 3 Units.
In Units 4 and 5, you figured out--
and hopefully understood--how to build the index
and then how to make it faster in Unit 5.
And in Unit 6--what we've just finished--
you figured out how to rank the results.
There's one little bit left:
we haven't used those ranks,
so one of the questions on your homework
will be using the ranks to get the best result.
If we want to get the best result, just having the dictionary ranks
is not enough--we need to use that to find
the result that matches the query that has the best rank.
And that's one of the questions that you'll do on the homework for this Unit.
There are a lot of other hard problems.
So you have a few problems left to solve
before you can build a search engine that will compete with Google.
Probably the hardest one: you've got to come up with a name.
This is really hard.
You could try "Yoogle",
You could try "DuckDuck Find".
None of those really work--you'll have to come up with a better name,
and this is a pretty tough problem.
Make sure to also talk to your Trademark lawyers.
Another thing you'd like to be able to do
is actually get your search engine on the Web
so other people can send queries to it.
That's not something we're going to cover in this class,
but if you take the Web Applications course
that will start shortly after this class finishes,
you'll learn a lot about how to build
Web applications and be able to do that.
So congratulations--you've reached the end of Unit 6.
And this is actually the last technical content
that will be in this course.
Unit 7 will get you ready for the final exam and will give you
some interesting examples of using Computing in Context.
So congratulations. You've now finished building a search engine
and it actually does Page Ranking
better than any search engine that existed before 1998.
That's quite amazing.
I first want to also congratulate David for getting you to this point.
I think that's quite amazing and, honestly, he's put a lot of
sleepless nights into thisl.
But also, i want to tell you: you guys are my heroes.
You got to a point where you reached something, I think,
really significant in this class--you actually learned how to--
And you programmed your own search engine.
Now, I have to say--I'm a little bit jealous.
When I was a student at college,
there was no search engines, and there wasn't even
and ability for me to learn all this stuff.
As for you, you've been afforded the ability to learn all this stuff.
But then you really got an amazing speed here.
That's something really, really significant.
I hope--I mean, if you keep up that speed
and keep improving yourself with that same speed and learn new things--
maybe in 3 or 4 years you are the next Google.
That would be really amazing.
Well, I think you're definitely on track to doing that,
and I hope you'll take some of the courses that we'll start offering,
as 200 available courses and more advanced courses later.
This is the end of Unit 6--we're not going to have
any more technical content to the course.
Unit 7 is going to be all field trips and interviews,
giving you some idea of how the things that you've learned in class
fit into Context--and that should be a lot of fun.
The other thing that you'll have, as part of Unit 7,
is the final exam.
And I hope everyone enjoys Homework 6
and will be ready for the final next week. >>And I hope you enjoy the final exam.